they know that mamajorov has stormed
ahead into the lead and they'll be
wanting to catch up meanwhile wow Magnus
isn't at the board and the clocks have
started Hikaru playing his first move
Magnus uh a bit of a Gambit already and
it's not even move one but you can see
that Nakamura is kind of shocked
that uh it did not show up at this time
and so is Magnus you know he seems to
indicate but he's not in a rush look at
that but this is this is magnus's power
move right we've seen him do that before
you know he when he arrived two and a
half minutes late for that game in the
blitz you know he literally adjusted all
his pieces before he made his move I
mean what kind of power move is that
wow and uh the game has started after
Magnus kind of gives Hikaru 30 seconds
lead on the clock and it's the exact
same opening shooter that we've seen
from Hikaru surprised not surprised he
decided this way he's not losing and
wasting energy rethink what to do yeah
let's go for it this is what I decided I
want to put my energy and they invest it
in other things in the middle game and
game
when you have to shuffle things the way
to to turn things around wow and Magnus
taking a long think it's only move six
this is really surprising kind of
forfeiting uh a few minutes on the clock
here pretty much and okay he plays
Bishop to F5 for a logical move
developing pieces and what does Hikaru
have in store just Rock Solid almost a
London system set up here for White and
the players will now just slowly develop
the pieces the action will be much later
in the game Magnus will hope that the
clock times balance out before that yeah
and uh Hikaru actually asking Magnus a
question now with this last queen move
he's just saying how are you going to
defend the pawn on B7 and still there
are some questions there because if the
queen does step forward I mean first of
all if I were playing with the white
pieces I would come in with my Bishop to
the B5 square and get ready to jump in
with the Knight on E5
yeah looks very tempting now the
question is whether Bishop B5 can be
played with an idea of Knight E5 and
what Magnus has in mind whether is he
really going to play F6 to stop that
well just to cover the E5 Square hoods
possible Magnus has done crazier stuff
but maybe he just wants to go Bishop D6
after Bishop B5
yeah well let's see yeah we'll find out
the answer to the question okay he
trades now now
is it too crazy to actually take that
night with the king the king will be
stranded in the center of the board for
the rest of the game that's true wow he
plays it Hikaru really desperate to win
here and Magnus reacts lightning fast
with F6 no night jumps for you and wow
I'm not sure it was a good sign that it
went this direction no it was a bit
one-track mind I think he needed to
because
with your king usually you're not
castling alongside in these systems
right right and and you and one other
thing that is quite concerning for white
is actually this light Square Bishop
that black has on the F5 Square because
the king is never going to find any
safety on the queen side with that piece
looming on the board
I mean black and even go very aggressive
G5 G4 kind of stuff
maybe not anymore Knight D4 alarm bells
ringing though E5 let's step forward
[Music]
really Breaking All the Rules because
you know we're taught first of all don't
move your king into the opening into the
center and then certainly don't open any
lines
he is fish a random world champion
though and this does look like official
random game with the King out on D2 so
will he get time after the queen trade
that's about to happen to run back with
his King to safety I'm really surprised
I must admit by magnus's last move very
strange go for checkmate when your
opponent's king is in the center that's
what we're taught but I think he's just
saying simply saying look the bishop on
G3 locked out of the game that's true
and uh let's continue the dancing on the
queen side it's a good G5
H5 yeah
stepping forward with all the pawns he's
going to gain gain space on both sides
on both flanks here as black it's still
a beautiful position here for Magnus but
I'm really shocked he didn't go for
checkmate to try and punish well maybe
he just wants to play for one result two
result sorry
things
will not feel too comfortable with this
with white because he just sits and wait
what kind of plans Magnus will work out
H4 G5 King G6 Rook d8
oops yeah what's this what's this D5 is
hanging yeah maybe just playing too slow
it feels like he's not quite in the zone
in this game instead of going for
checkmate he's been forced to allow a
bunch of Trades don't forget that Bishop
on H2 yeah one bad piece that's White's
problem long term right has nine pounds
maybe nine pawns and uh not enough
pieces
yeah okay but at least some pressure has
been relieved with this uh last exchange
this must have been very instructive
C5 C4 sorry in every game and every game
somewhere a place it seems to be like
the formula right gets you develop
pieces get C4 in
some tactics some tricks here you have
to be really careful it's black actually
this Pawn's being undermined and your
knight is really loose in the center of
the board yeah now it's
anyone's game I mean it's White's idea
so if black were to double Rooks on the
C line this is simply to go B4 Pro or a
problem for white for black that Rook CA
does not work because C takes D5 Rook
cakes on E6 and captures the Knight on
on e4 and okay the H2 Bishop is bad but
two Bishop versus The Rook is plus yeah
yeah huge threats how does Magnus deal
with this Portland takes Pawn is a
winning idea if he gets time Hikaru
Nakamura suddenly the clocks as well
Magnus down to 30 seconds he's going to
regret kind of forfeiting that 30
seconds he played too fast made
decisions
oh wow what action it is all happening
fire on the board lots of calculation to
be done
and right now white can go upon up in
the end game if they just uh if Hikaru
here just takes this black Bishop with
the check and then recaptures on F3 but
he's thinking of something else but does
if he were to grab that pawn
his Bishop on H2 would be saddled there
until the end of times
and that's something that is
strategically rarely really concerning
very interesting this move with Magnus
played G4
he's not scared of getting his Knight
trapped on the edge of the board I would
be slightly uh kind of worried here if I
were Magnus Carlson this Black Knight
has no Escape squares that's why Hikaru
has stepped forward F4 taking away the
G5 Square from black snipe now all
Hikaru needs is to teleport his King
over to G2 wow no way back now for that
piece
Magnus playing with fire
King F1 Retreat Rog G8 took C7 and
White's playing with an extra piece
essentially the white king the white
Bishop they're kind of canceling out the
black Rook at night right now Magnus is
totally stuck totally immobilized
I hate what magdus has been doing and
there we go Judith White's Rook is
activating
could we see white just be winning in
the next few moves
it's quite a funny setup having the
bishop on H2 Knight on H3 don't try it
at home that's uh the problem actually
the bishop is coming into the game
Magnus Magnus wriggling hard you know
mother Rick has come to G4 G4 4 is
threatened on the board
takes H4 yes
takes and then you go H4 you win back
the piece you win back the white Bishop
at the end but I don't understand why
hikaru's there we go not just activating
his Rook you can hit my Bishop but I'll
just happily Retreat and the black
Knight's still trapped for the rest of
the game
that's under 20 seconds and his
signing
positions more than concerning it might
just be lost here and under 10 seconds
as you say Ivanka
what next where's he going with that
black king really mysterious stuff he
can barely move and now Nakamura is just
going Pawn hunting going for Black's
pawns on the queen side grab them why
not well
how many seconds 15 seconds for Hikaru
and he's taken some time out just to see
whether he can grab the pawn and that's
a good King G4
and now what Knight F2 King H3 he has
his magic ideas this is the definition
of magic Judith look at what he's done
the black king has crept into the
position he's going for the win Magnus
if he can get his King into the F3
Square Hikaru has to pull the brakes and
he has to do it now
he's a piece up Hikaru but uh White's
Bishop is so trapped and the clock is
ticking down and the King has come to F3
wow what a resource by Magnus well the
pawns are disappearing still some
Checkmate threats blacks eporn
threatening to come forward and look at
the clock both players seconds left
decision there from Magnus F4
he's just not taking a free Pawn that
feels like
now
Magnus has got to draw up his sleeve if
he wants it it feels like he can bring
his King across his car is just
repeating now bringing his Rook trying
to give a check hey Magnus takes the
pawn black has to be the favorite hatred
well the those two extra pawns F4 F3 and
nothing will stop him F3
keep pushing
now go three three times around still
he's just repeating moves here get any
time on the clock the players do have a
two second increment
but he's stuck how can he break through
here Magnus Carlsen getting F3 and it's
gone
two E2 and Rook B1
Judah I think you spotted a direct win
there he's still going to find it though
Magnus Carson he's got three pawns now
the B Pawn running
Hikaru is about to resign three pawns is
too much he's relaxed
what kind of H3 Knight he had
and I mean oh my God what a game what a
turnaround I mean this just goes to show
it's all about holding the nerves when
the clock is ticking down on its final
seconds and here comes F3 oh what's that
isn't F what's the f f at this point
rolling black is about to win
what a painful loss for Nakamura this is
not the way Magnus wanted to win
no but there's such a genius plan giving
up his night and just entering with the
black king just so resourceful to see
that idea that plan from moves ahead
with no time on his clock Magnus
deserving it in the end but yeah earlier
play questionable to say the least well
it was basically after the opening it
was like full huge Advantage right
and there you can see the big smile on
magnus's face because he knows he got
away with it